no sooner had Abu Ali's family thought
they'd found somewhere to stay the
landowner moved them on this is how it's
been for hundreds of thousands of
Syrians throughout the seven years civil
war traveling further and further north
to escape the fighting
this displacement is never-ending I
never expected to be in this situation
no one knows what will happen next
the fighters don't seem to know if they
should advance or the regime will
advance on them the traffic is mostly
one way as people had away from the
advancing government forces towards the
last rebel stronghold of Eid Lib
province the Syrian regime now controls
all of the countryside in Hama province
south of it Lib after taking over with
Russian help the last villages and towns
that have been in rebel hands
it all happened under the noses of
Turkish soldiers there behind this wall
in one of a dozen observation posts
established to monitor what are supposed
to be de-escalation zones our
observation posts are not besieged there
nobody can beseech our troops or
observation posts I want to clarify it
yes there are attacks in the region of
adalah the regime is active around our
observation posts we are discussing this
issue with Russia and Iran turkey is
also worried that regime advances will
push more than half a million Syrians to
its border the regime is taking
everything they are giving us a kicking
yesterday six helicopters over our heads
force us to leave all night there was
bombing the ground was shaking under our
legs Turkey's president has told his
Russian counterpart that Syrian military
attacks in northwestern Syria are
causing a humanitarian crisis pledget
type-1 told blood amir putin that what's
happening there threatens turkish
national security it's one of the
reasons turkey is so keen to get a safe
zone up and running on the Syrian side
of the border but so far there's still
no indication that Turkey has agreed
with the US military on who will patrol
this zone and how deep into Syria it
will go Burnett Smith al Jazeera and
tachea